[Music]
what the hell is this I knew I was weird
but I know is this weird these days it's
really easy to see somebody when they've
arrived and that's because they become
visible to you after many years of work
but often we ignore the massive amount
of effort it took for that person to get
there the years of small iterative
improvements to every failure misstep
and detour along the way hi I'm Matthew
and Sina and if this is the first time
we're meeting I've worked as a creative
professional for over 15 years in the
design and advertising space and now I
make content on YouTube to share with
you everything that I've learned along
the way so today in this video I want to
share my personal creative journey thus
far by going back at least 20 years of
my creative portfolio work until now so
you can get an idea of how I've
developed my skills over time what work
got me work and how my career evolved
over the time that I've been in the
industry so sit back relax we're gonna
time travel back to 1998 and I'm gonna
take you on a journey from my earliest
work doing not-so-good drawings and
self-portraits up until now where I'm
directing commercials for Xbox and bands
like Coldplay
enjoy
okay my parents have held on to most of
my work since my childhood and luckily I
found this still intact which is all of
my high school portfolio work let's see
what do we got in here
it all kinds of drawings at the time my
head in my high school I went to public
high school which was a Mayfair High
School in Lakewood at the time they had
just started this brand new program was
called the Art Academy it was the first
time that the school had received grant
money to be able to start the
specialized art program you had to apply
yet to show up portfolio and I had some
chicken scratch drawings from sixth
grade or seventh grade to send and apply
there and I got in and I was part of the
first class to be part of this pilot
program and it was pretty fantastic so
we had these worksheets in high school
where we would have to learn about all
the different color harmonies and then
we would have to fill it out with I
think color pencil something like that
oh here we go okay
self-portrait number one but this is me
is it does this look like me Ricky not
really you'll see throughout my lifetime
I had many many haircuts and before back
in the day I used to split my hair right
down the middle a different medium
another self-portrait I was under lit
here this is ballpoint pen oh yeah this
okay this is definitely one of the
earlier ones this has to be right at
ninth grade at that
does that look like me that does not
it's a stretch I'll agree with Ricki and
this one this one does not look like me
you could tell again I'm very timid with
the medium shading kind of light not so
good the proportions are kind of off
look how long my nose is I didn't quite
get it I think we found the mother lode
here yeah I think it's pretty your
parents know their self portrait so it
looks like me right I have orange skin
and purple hair again I was very
uncomfortable with wet medium so it was
so much harder to control and surrender
and for this one I think the assignment
was probably to start in shades of grey
and then paint over it with color so we
had to layer on top of it so first we
studied value and then we put in colors
and these ones I think we're
complementary colors my guess is because
we have these yellow and orange against
the purple and the blues see we did a
lot of life drawing as you can see I
think this is probably from tenth grade
I love the drawing people's folded
clothing or pants so these were little
life drawings that we did it's all right
make this was ninth grade this was
coming off of the color theory
assignment so I think we have to paint
something I don't know what the heck I
was thinking but I think this was all
about like a Wild West I think was the
theme and then this is him hanging there
I believe because he's paying for his
crimes
this is at the same time that the new
wave of IMAX had come out and my school
invested in them all of the computers
were loaded up with Adobe Creative Suite
strata Studio Pro which was a 3d program
at the time and painter which was good
for like 2d animation we got to explore
I got to sink my teeth into digital art
for the very first time in my life and
at the time I was very inspired by all
the animated films from Disney I was
heavily inspired by movies like
Terminator 2 all of the Star Wars films
the old ones and the new ones that were
coming out at the time because they were
so CG heavy all the Pixar films the
Pixar films were a phenomenal Toy Story
had just come out a few years prior
once I saw those examples out there once
I saw a couple of
find the scenes of how it's made I think
that really inspired me and at this time
from ninth to tenth grade or so I really
wanted to be an animator 3d animator
this was the first 3d model I ever built
made me feel that much closer to my
dream of becoming an animator this was
painted in Photoshop stroke by stroke
just like line by line and I would be
doing that I have a gut feeling it was
around 2 weeks long and that was the
thing about the Art Academy is that
they're the deadlines weren't that
strict as my teacher mrs. moles would
say an artist has never done and that
has stuck with me for my entire life
maybe at the time I was being a little
lazy and how I interpreted that but I
know what she really meant was that you
can keep perfecting forever and it's
visit constant iteration that you're
gonna be doing your entire life or on
your masterpiece and that's how you
should be approaching things it's like
you're never gonna be done and if you
can accept that fact then you know
you'll you'll be very happy being an
artist so what comes to mind for me when
I think of myself at this time I was
very shy even my choice in going to
college I didn't prep for that at all I
wasn't confident in that I would end up
at University I just started applying to
the local art schools I applied to the
Art Institute of Los Angeles and that's
where most of my peers that I went to
high school with I would say a third of
them applied there and actually got in
so because and will follow her at this
time and I'm very timid to go out on my
own I just followed them over there I
also applied with my high school
portfolio and I signed up for the
graphic design program and that set me
up for the next part of my life which is
college let's put this away don't you
think I look at my college work
all right so I had just graduated high
school in 2002 at the ripe age of 17 and
I followed my friends over to Art
Institute because that's where most of
my art friends were going I had applied
to the graphic design program because
that's kind of what I wanted to do I
guess but I really know what I was
getting myself into I didn't really know
what the full program entail so luckily
I have preserved quite a bit of the work
that I had done here at Art Institute
and some of these things I had acquired
digitally luckily my parents held on to
a lot of this work but some of these
things I had to dig up from these guys
zip this so my early work look something
like this is for a digital illustration
class it was just learning about
illustrator because I think this was
just like a little flyer or something or
a banner for this fictitious event
called soul education you can see from
this silhouette here I was very into the
Gorillaz and I love the art style so you
could see I'm just totally copying that
right there as I progressed through the
program I started doing I started
learning about typography typography was
something I didn't know before but I
started doing more of these like
Photoshop collages using typography at
the time I was very into pop punk but
else I dug up these are CDs I had you
can see this is the aesthetic of the
time this is Thursday you can see they
all have this kind of vintage look to
them something corporate this this type
of music this type of artwork heavily
influenced my work but has to give you a
picture of what I was listening to what
I was influenced by and then how that
took place and some of the work that I
was doing and this like early typography
explorations we're getting a little bit
more mature about how I understand
composition I started to learn about
negative space cuz obviously before I
didn't know it that was so lots of
negative space I don't know what this
was I know this is
a photo of me when I was a little kid
and I just you can see there's a little
bit more of a sophistication and
adaptation of some of the stuff that I
liked on some of these music album
covers one thing about being around an
art program is everybody there is very
progressive in their thinking have lots
of alternative views were very into
counterculture which much of this I had
discovered and heard of for the very
first time in my life the corruption of
politicians genetically modified foods
like all this stuff was introduced to me
for the very first time in my brain was
spinning so I got very angry at the
world that this time was like oh my gosh
everything is corrupt but this was after
9/11 and then a whole bunch of stuff we
started getting very involved in the
Middle East and at the time was like
very passionately against that so it
started to show up in my work and I saw
this in other places in the album art in
people like Banksy magazines like
Adbusters Adbusters was a huge magazine
that I was influenced by okay now we're
gonna see some more political stuff and
you'll see how some of my early
influences came out in the rest of my
work so this was a political poster and
the concept here was the political lies
the dirty hands the the lies they tell
us and you can see there's something up
his sleeve so this type is falling out
of his sleep so this is a highly
conceptual at this point I started
taking another layer of communicating an
idea I'm not really caring about the
medium but just using all the tools that
I knew at the time again I was very
politically charged and I was like oh my
gosh that everybody's telling us lies
all these people in power and telling us
lies and you know I felt this and this
is how I communicated that so here's the
next thing very charged this is a this I
said the concept here is the minority
experience regarding the glass ceiling
in corporate America so I was trying to
tie this idea of corporate life as a
person of color you can't make it very
far whether you think the message in
here was good or bad or whatever side
you fall on the thing that was powerful
from me out
side of the expression was that I was
creating I was making making things that
I thought that mattered and I was
scratching this really deep itch for me
that I didn't know that I had which is I
have an idea I want to communicate it in
an interesting way why not use design
and all the other mediums that I've been
exploring throughout the years and that
I think is the reason why I think my
work it was very powerful at the time
and I think some of the things that got
me into art centre because they could
see the conceptual thinking here and
this is something that I've continued to
sharpen over time throughout my work
even until this day of course not
everything was dark I still had fun I
was still even though I was a bit of an
emo kid you know like I still had fun
making these type explorations because
the images were so cool but I wanted to
explore with color and typography so I
had a lot of fun at the time like I said
I was very into this kind of
counterculture look so I was very into
collage stuff and you could see my
collage work actually got a lot more
sophisticated so this is where the band
lost dry severs their whole thing was
kind of talking about the the border and
the kind of the cross culture effect
that their music has it's like music
brings people together doesn't matter
what your background is so a lot of the
nature of their music was like that and
I wanted to make this cool poster for
them and so this is completely
fictitious just a student project but
you can see it I cut out all these
things I said all the type I photograph
this myself on pink paper and this
turned out to be the poster so I've
really leaned into this and I started to
understand my voice as a person who
could use mixed media photography
typography leaning into everything I
knew about Photoshop so this is one of
the pieces like I said I was very into
pop punk at the time and one of my
friends in school his name is Chris
floret he was working for a magazine
called scratch magazine and he saw my
work he's like dude I love your work
we're hiring at scratch magazine which I
worked for so he gave me some as his
overflow freelance work and the first
thing I designed
was the cover of the magazine so this
was for the February Valentine's issue
kid sees like very dark there's this
cool illustration of a heart it's
bleeding and all these breakup
relationship images here all this a
chicken scratch type and this was the
first time I have forgot something
printed that I was so proud but that was
the cover and then you'll see below it
these are some of the spreads that I
designed not so great like my typography
was okay but I thought it was a good
real world example of stuff I put out
there so these are things here as part
of my portfolio I still did identity
work brand identity work so this was
from my friends b-boy event called Sol
Cal you can see I made the collateral
for this here's some of the collateral
that we made so I made this little
business card for him so it would be a
die-cut and then it would reveal all the
information there right so there's his
name James but I thought it would be
cool to do a die-cut of a city so this
is so fun to make so fun to dream up so
I went to Art Institute not really
knowing what I wanted to do I fell into
graphic design and then I found my voice
using the medium to communicate and then
I started to really enjoy it I started
to really like that and I met a couple
of instructors who pushed me they saw my
work and they said you know what I think
you're kind of wasting your talents here
at Art Institute Art Institute was
pretty good at teaching me technical
skills but I don't think that the
students around me were pushing like I
was and I had a few instructors Nick
Matt and Joslyn who all went to art
Center by the way and they saw my work
and they said you know what you should
apply to Art Center if you're really
serious about being a graphic designer
and pursuing a career in that you should
go to art Center and we'll help you I
spent the rest of my time at Art
Institute working on my portfolio to get
into art center and when I finally went
home to go tell my mom and said mom mom
I'm gonna apply to Art Center first
thing she said is like how much is that
gonna cost and I was so stubborn at
first it's like what why does that
matter it's like I need to do this thing
you know I need I need to explore this
career like I'm I'm taking it serious
and
getting what I need a heart institute
and she's like well hmm you know you're
asking for the moon and the stars here
you're already in debt and you don't
realize it yet you already spent money
going to the school and you're not
paying the loans yet but you will when
you get out I just worry for you so
after some discussion over a dinner and
I just like I think I can let you go to
Art Center but the contingency is you
have to get a scholarship to get in I
said okay
I said okay thank you thank you so much
mom I'll get that scholarship so when I
graduated from Art Institute and applied
to Arts Center I got this letter of
recommendation from two of my
instructors from Matt and Jocelyn who
ran this company called deaf I design
and they had such nice things to say I
just want to read you the last part cuz
I thought this was a very much still Who
I am today Matthew understands that
design begins with a good idea it's not
just the icing on the cake so that part
was very powerful for me because I think
that encapsulated what I learned in this
period of college in this period of my
life were in high school I was just very
much about learning how to render
learning how to make something pretty
learning the tools in college I was
learning how to communicate an idea what
is the message and how can I best
articulate that message and that was
designed for me that's what was in this
letter and I think that's what
ultimately got me into art center so I
applied to Art Center after graduating
from art Institute at the end of 2004 I
got a letter I opened it and it came in
this fancy package it was this it was so
art center is this like iridescent gray
package and I can see inside I was like
ooh they're spending money on this
packaging this must be a good sign I
opened it said I got accepted yes
but I was holding out for the
contingency did I get a scholarship
reading through reading through yes oh
my gosh all that hard work yes they gave
me a scholarship for about 45 percent of
my tuition so not only did I get the
great news of getting accepted getting
scholarship I also got to skip a term so
here I am finally confident in my work
finally confident as me as an individual
as a designer and I walk into Art Center
ready to conquer feel good about my
typography skills my grid skills color
like everything feel like I got it ready
and I have a voice
of course I walk into that classroom the
first day and then there's ten other
students just like me I go to
orientation there's dozens of others
that's just like me just as driven just
as talented I felt like oh wow I haven't
really experienced this before a bunch
of people who are so driven and so
motivated and we're already doing killer
work is once I started at Art Center it
was so much work I would be doing
all-nighters all the time I'd be
spending a lot of time in the labs or
driving back and back and forth from
home to school and that was a 40 mile
drive I couldn't afford to live on
campus or anywhere close to campus so I
still was commuting from home so a lot
of my time and energy was just poured
into school in my typography to class
which and I was doing work like this so
this was a poster that we had made that
each of us get to choose a city and
we're making a poster to help
communicate what it's like like what you
can do is kind of like the Trip Advisor
at the time other things that I did this
was part of my communication design
class we have to make this little
booklet that would tell the story of any
character in history so of Harry Houdini
who is essentially a magician and an
escape artist so here on the front of
course he's not there he's not visible
he's cut out he's physically gone from
the space so again just playing with
this conceptual idea of like here's a
story here's what I'm trying to
communicate about his life and how can I
do it an interest
way with the composition with the images
and the typography yeah so that was one
of the early communication design
classes just to help us practice telling
a story and unfold in sequential design
which was very big that was one thing
that I just didn't really know much of
yet but started to understand here so in
a booklet in TV commercial animation any
of this stuff anything that happens over
time that is sequential design and
that's the early part of what we're
exploring here this next project was
probably one of my favorite projects
that I made at Art Center even though I
made it and think in the fourth term I
still displayed it on my portfolio when
I graduated and these were a set of
posters that I created from the song
1980 X which is a song from the band
head automatic oh this whole thing was
made with a set of transparencies and a
bunch of photoshop so let me give you a
little bit of context for the song the
song 1980 X the lyrics so here's the big
line that I anchored on I live in hopes
that I could live up to me that line was
so powerful and it's this idea that he
this character he lives in a home life
where everyone has high expectations of
him and he's letting everybody down so
this was very powerful for me when I
discovered this project recently I was
like Tim that still speaks to me today
that one particular line I took this and
then I started distorting it and you can
see all these crazy details in the image
here like these cracks all of that was
practical I discovered this technique
and I forget where it came from but I
printed these images on transparencies
and then I destroyed them with Windex
and a bunch of other cleaning products
like that I love that see how it could
have distorts or it says hopes and it's
kind of tweaked I live in hopes that I
can live up to music that's that is
crazy right there yeah for me I think
the reason why this quote is so powerful
to me to this line is so powerful to me
is I grew up in a home I grew up in a
immigrant culture my parents had come
here didn't have much and worked and
clawed their way up to
where we got to live to where we are
today and for me they always celebrated
all the little things that I did all the
little students of the month and all the
awards that I got so always felt so good
because I was supported at home I felt
so good because they celebrated the wins
for me but I think over time the the
thing that that actually did for me even
though it's so positive and good and
intent it made me think that oh my gosh
I always have to get an A oh my gosh I
should always do well in school oh my
gosh I have to do something worth
celebrating so that in the back of my
mind kind of develops and I don't think
that was intentional by my parents at
all cuz they're loving sweet people but
they kept doing that and I think for me
that created this impostor syndrome this
feeling that there's this version of me
that's up here and I'm still down here
and I always have to be up here if
someone wants to recognize me so when I
see when I saw this line and I read that
today there's still parts of me that
feels this way that the expectation of
Who I am the thing that you guys are
perceived me for is something that's
very difficult to live up to sometimes
so that's why this line is so powerful
and I think a lot of people feel that as
well that was the first four terms at
Art Center and by this point I felt like
men
I figured everything out when it came to
print or at least that was my arrogance
kicking in and I think I was getting a
little bit bored to be honest that by
fourth term I was like you know is this
what I'm gonna do for the next couple of
terms is there gonna be anything else
because I mean I'm kind of doing similar
stuff that I was doing at the tail end
of Art Institute so I was starting to
feel a little bit stagnant and then I
got introduced to motion design and
motion design was a game changer for me
while I was arts and I told you there
were so many people who are just amazing
at what they did and there was one
particular person that I had met and his
name was Chris reel so as part of my
track at Art Center in the graphic
design program I had to take a motion
one class which is just an After Effects
class I had to understand moving image
because it was part of the sequential
design like how do you
communicate something overtime when I
took this class there was this TA his
name was Chris real he was also a
student he was my peer I had him in a
class and he was very good and I was
like you're the TA for this class like
I'm gonna learn from you and I think
that started a little bit of
competitiveness in me it's like you're
telling me you know more than I do and
the you know something about this motion
design that I don't and he's like yeah
motion design is a thing and that's
actually why I came to Art Center
because I'm going to be a motion
designer now scratching my head is like
that's a thing you can do that as a job
all of these things change my trajectory
I started to sink in very deep I was
already committed to school but this
made me go really deep into something
learning something new because I at this
time I only had a little over a year
left at heart center and I knew if I
wanted to do this for a career I had to
develop a portfolio that looks amazing
and I had zero at this point it had zero
motion design pieces in my portfolio so
I would focus the last year in making
this work taking as many classes as I
could and then I did this one very big
project and this was in my compositing
class that I took with ming-tai
and we did a music video one of my
friends hooked us up with a local band
and we decided to do a music video so
the concept here as you see this crazy
weird-looking bird and this guy he wakes
up in this space it's like what the hell
or am i and he's kind of walking towards
his bed here and we cut to this other
world this is the real world where as I
came in as friends and they're having
breakfast this is all shot on green
screen on stage they're having their
breakfast and then we're kind of
starting to go back and forth between
these two worlds I was like these are
actually the band members so there's all
sleeping hunt this bed and this bird we
called him Morton because he's made out
of Morton box salt and then all of us
are in this bed that they're laying down
on wakes up and it starts moving and
then we have this shot here that we
composite I'm so proud this is my
favorite shot from the whole thing
but we shot this on the jib arm shooting
down on them on green screen and so
we're kind of going back and forth we're
showing like wait a minute the
dreamworld is starting to affect the
real world because this plant had just
grown in the foreground and then all of
a sudden something's happening the world
is shaking here and then this is all
distorting so the the milk on the table
is spilling the cereal is spilling and
then we're just going back and forth
back and forth from this dream world
back into the real world and we're
seeing this giant bed with legs which is
even higher now walking through the
forest walking further and further these
guys were so fun to shoot they're so
sweet they're so nice but then you see
like okay now they're in suburbia this
dream world is crossing over into
suburbia and what happened is this big
bed this dream world is now intersecting
this neighborhood and boom the foot of
the bed comes crashing through and it's
actually intersecting with the real
world so the real world like guys who
are awakened the guys that were dreaming
kind of got knocked out by this dream
world and then this guy goes to sleep
and then here we go and it loops and
we're back at the beginning crazy so
weird but it was so fun because these
were the things that me and my partners
that worked on this mean Chris real
worked on this we love this stuff we
loved mixed-media and I think him and I
got along because I quickly learned
about motion design he taught me
everything he knew and that was
fantastic
and I think both of us had an
appreciation and respect for each
other's work so we you know we had a
good time at this point I knew that this
was going to be the career for me after
I graduated from art Center this is what
I was going to do because I was clearly
excited about this I was clearly jazzed
about this and this was so fun and new
and exciting and motion design combined
so many elements that I've been building
up to to this point and all of a sudden
this confidence comes out from me the
confident person who knows what they're
doing
still has a lot of room to grow and
explore but is confident in that
uncertainty because I know that if I put
my mind to it if I experiment and I
explore and now that I have a buddy this
guy Chris real I can make something
amazing for it for me I've always
battled with feeling a little
insignificant feeling a little quiet
quiet and insecure now I'm starting to
come out on the other side of this work
it's like shoot maybe I do have a voice
in this world maybe I do belong
somewhere and maybe I have something
bigger to contribute and I'm okay with
putting that out there then I met this
other person this person that I didn't
realize would change my life forever
somebody who still continues to
influence me today this guy is known as
Krystal was one of the infamous teachers
that you've heard about during school
everybody knows who Chris though is even
in the context of school because he
taught at Art Center and he taught at
Otis and he had done it for over 15
years when I took his class in 2006 that
guy barely smiled if you present
something to him he would just sit there
in silence and then the students look
after they present their work to like oh
but you know I didn't finish this thing
yet and you know I still got to work on
this frame and I go you know the being
the immature students that we were like
we're still trying to impress this dude
trying to figure out what the heck is
this guy thinking we were so
uncomfortable in the silence but all he
was doing at the time was processing his
thoughts and he'd already reached this
level of let me listen and I'm not gonna
speak until I have figured out what I
want to say and that's just him that's
how he's processing I think that's how I
was processing it he was very
intelligent he was very much the person
to challenge your way of thinking he
would not let you put up mediocre work
and leave it there he would ask you so
many questions or make really important
insights and suggestions for how you can
improvement and he always pushed every
in the class and that's why he was so
infamous that's why everybody wanted to
take his class is because he won't let
you phone it in he won't let you slide
here's this guy who supposedly is the is
the guy to take and he didn't disappoint
so this is just the overview of the
advanced motion communication class he
gave us this assignment it's called the
butterfly effect the world is all
connected and if something happens here
there's an effect somewhere else so
cause and effect so it was as open as
that and he challenges us first it's
like okay first I want you to figure out
what your concept is then I want you to
sketch out storyboards and present your
idea to the class and then you're gonna
get into design style frames so I came
to class and my idea again being the
political person that I am I decided to
do one on the Iraq war and these are the
black-and-white storyboards that I had
sketched for his class so my concept was
the Iraq war was ludicrous and so I
wanted to figure out what is a
interesting way to show that idea and I
thought of combining it with pinball
pinball I've always loved pinball as a
game so that was my POV that was my
concept but it took me probably like 45
minutes to draw one of these things and
there's maybe 20 frames here so imagine
I spent all night from the day before
his class all the way up until his class
drawing these things I didn't sleep and
that was the reoccurring thing going
into Chris's class I never slept for his
class because I spent every hour that I
could working on the project to show him
I wanted to impress him I wanted him to
say yes that's good or to even beat me
down and that was okay because I wanted
to go through the process of learning
from this guy who is making me sharper
who's challenging my ideas and
sharpening my conceptual thinking which
I really enjoyed so that was for Chris's
class and actually ended up animating
this piece so this piece I've fully
animated in 3d and it was part of my
advanced 3d class so I did a co-op where
I did the storyboards in Chris's class
and then I would execute them in another
class because I really wanted to see
this
through so you saw my earlier 3d
animation not so great this one got a
little bit better than this one I did
over one term or half of a term for my
advanced 3d motion graphics class
pinball flies out and then it flies into
this machine where you see all of our
characters this is the Bush
administration right here and all the
ways to win the game
[Music]
so I was trying to communicate all these
major events that were happening after
the Iraq war I was so proud of this just
because I had never painted style frames
like this before and this was just a
combination of photo compositing a
little bit of 3d and just making it work
and that was the beautiful thing that
I'd start to learn about motion design
and painting style frames is you just
make it work you figure out how to make
it work there's no rules for how to
actually do it well because it was so
new and it was so much about mixed-media
and even my early days of making those
stupid collages in Photoshop helped me
here it helped me understand how to
compose these things and how to build
the frames that told the story and were
very interesting and this was my
graduating real that I had put together
in 2007
and I was so proud of this stuff because
that's like men in a year I accomplished
so much all of this was done within a
year and that was a hard switch from
leaving the print world going into
motion design and I was so proud and it
combined all these things that I was
into animation sequential design
conceptual design communication
everything was all mixed-media and you
could still see parts of the things that
I did in my early college career and
like how it brought to this and then I
got introduced to people who were very
into illustration into 2d animation and
I got to collaborate with them to make
all these cool pieces and when I
graduated I was ready to conquer the
world and that actually leads me to the
next part of the story which is what
happened to me after Art Center all
right guys
sorry but there's a little bit of a
cliffhanger here I know I was gonna
share with you what happens after Art
Center but as you can tell this video is
already running along so we decided to
cut it into two parts and part two is
linked down below in that video we're
gonna cover my journey as a creative
professional going out in the real world
now owning my own business becoming a
freelancer and then working as a staff
creative director at blind so I hope to
share all of that with you in part 2
don't forget to watch that if you did
learn something from it let me know in
the comments below or share it with a
friend by sharing this video it really
helps us out as a channel to know that
you guys value and like this stuff and
that we should do more like this so
anything that I mentioned in this video
I'll be putting it in the links in the
description below and if you guys have
more questions about stuff I'll be
adding as many resources in there so
check their often don't forget to check
me out at Matthew in sina.com and at
Matthew and Cena on all the socials I'll
see you guys in the future
Oh